so good news for hoodie and Jim shorts
loving John fetterman the U.S Senate
will no longer be subject to a dress
code of the traditional suit and tie
while on the senate floor Chuck Schumer
making it official saying this senators
are able to choose what they wear on the
senate floor I will continue to wear a
suit wow how big of him okay so talk
about a two-tiered fashion system the
new dress code only applies to Senators
not to the staff and others they are
still expected to remain in business
attire this could only happen in
Washington
judge they're lowering the standards for
one person one guy and how does this
help him or anybody else well it's the
amazing thing is I mean if they thought
about what they did and how many votes
it takes to get something done all of a
sudden they have one guy saying Schumer
is saying for the benefit of fetterman
you know you can wear whatever you want
and yet the staffers who barely make a
living you have to go out and buy you
know fancy clothes this guy looks like
he's in a gang or he's working out
somewhere and but the house has to stay
dressed up they have to wear a jacket
and a tie you know maybe women should
start wearing Lululemon I mean in the
Senate is it just the men in the Senate
I think the whole thing is horrible I
think it's part of the deterioration of
this country for one guy that guy
they're going to change the rules
ridiculous and how long does it stay in
effect well probably Harold until the
Republicans win the Senate back
yeah we'll see I I agree with the judge
I think this is um an Abomination to our
to to the way government should conduct
itself if you have a health issue or a
medical issue that requires you not to
be able to dress I get it but if you're
able to dress you should have to wear
shirt and tie on a jacket not a suit uh
and real shoes on the senate floor in
the house floor I'm just kind of
old-fashioned about these things I grew
up in a school went to school in
Washington we had to wear a shirt and
tie and a jacket every day to school and
I got to tell you it helped so I'm weird
thank you thank you Greg he said he's so
surprised I'm as comfortable in a
certain time which is another whole
conversation we should have as I am
anything else but it also I think helps
you to get more organized it helps
people uh I think to to to to to to
think more seriously about what they're
doing and I hope that Senator Schumer I
know it was his decision I disagree with
it I hope you change your mind on this
and I hope if amount if Republicans and
when Republicans do regain a majority in
the Sin I hope they change it and I hope
that McCarthy in the house that they
don't do this uh not to mention the
equity issue which you don't allow the
staffers and other but you're going to
allow one person to do it I think right
it's like the covid rules they're for
everybody else but not for them and Greg
you have major trust and confidence
issues in the institutions right and the
Democrats and Republicans say this is a
major problem and here you have somebody
who is part of the conversation to spend
millions of our taxpayer dollars on
things and he gets to wear gym clothes
to work well when asked if he was happy
about the change fetterman blinked twice
for yes but fetterman come on even
Frankenstein wore a suit jacket right
yeah it was a little ill-fitty but I
have to say
I think this might be good for women
because women have horrible choices for
business attire I think I mean why do
women dress in the senate or congress
they look like captains from a cruise
ship it's like every woman looks like a
ship's Purser do you ever notice that
the little the big lapels men are
different we need the discipline I agree
with Harold or we will revert back to
slobber if we didn't have standards here
I'd be like in a mesh half shirt in
sweatpants no way yes I would I would
stop staring at me Harold but it's at
the men's if men don't have standards
imposed on them they stop caring and I
think women should wear what they want
and dress how comfortable they want
because women know how to dress they
know they they do they enjoy looking
good men enjoy looking comfortable so I
think the dudes should stick to the
suits this isn't a poker game or a strip
club you know it's it's not it's not
going for lunch at the Cheesecake
Factory so but it's we are doing a
decline of standards in everything yep
you know this happened in the fall of
the Roman Empire they let people wear
togas everywhere yep next thing you know
damn Empire Jesse doesn't know what the
Roman Empire is no I don't know what the
toga is
so Civilization now celebrates
mediocrity you're pandering to the
lowest common denominator and now
existing is just an accomplishment and
that's what we're doing in this country
if you reduce competition and you're an
elitist then you say everybody shouldn't
have to strive we'll stay on top you
stay down there it's almost like a
psychological uh psyop in order to tell
people you know what you stay in your
place you wear your hoodie if you look
at how models are these days models
aren't that good looking you look at
them in the 70s and the 80s they were
all smokes not anymore if you go and you
look outside at the beach everyone has a
tattoo that's
don't tell him I said that yeah don't
tell them and if you're a sick or an
unhealthy person then you're a victim
and victims are now Heroes so they
probably pulled it and they said you
know working class Blue Collar voters in
Pennsylvania will see themselves in John
Federman and that'll help us you know
win I don't see that I think people look
at the guy and they're disgusted judge
how do we bring back manners and
etiquette
is it possible yeah I worry about crime
um but I think that it's Schumer who
made this decision we've gotta you know
we've got to make sure we get someone
else in who just changes that opinion uh
I don't I don't know how else to do it I
mean are adults teaching their kids I
mean are your kids going to school with
a jacket and tie well they wear a
uniform right now they're not sure to
tell you but I hope so so
back I mean that was cute yes yeah go
back yeah we love roback yes we do yep
we all do all right one more thing is up
next hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else